ich beschäftige mich natürlich mit der
eigenen und der neuen familienministerin
und haben gerade schon über die qualität
der regierung geredet und ich habe in
dem zusammenhang kommt man nicht ganz
ran vorbei auch mal über quo und
proporzwahl zu reden und
identitätspolitik im weitesten sinne
also war ja regierungen heutzutage
offensichtlich fast systematisch daran
gehindert sind positionen mit leuten zu
besetzen die das irgendwie gut können
oder davor erfahrung haben sondern es
wird also quotiert wie wild also
mann/frau
jungen links rechts natürlich immer
regionalproporz nordrhein westfalen
mecklenburg vorpommern dann gibt es
vielleicht noch so sonderkategorien frau
feser sollte eine schöne stadt position
haben für den wahlkampf in hessen wo sie
dann ja spitzenkandidatin der spd werden
will wir haben mit frau lambrecht sicher
niemand der sozusagen mit der bundeswehr
im blut aufgewachsen ist also die
fremdelt ja doch sehr und hat große
schwierigkeiten
und ja wir haben jetzt die situation
frau spiegel musste gehen die neue
kandidatin konnte aber auf gar keinen
fall ein mann sein also die vorstellung
dass wir einfach mal einen
heterosexuellen mann als familienmutter
kriegen völlig undenkbar ist musste
wieder eine linke grüne frau sein das
heißt wir mauern uns oder die regierung
macht sich somit ihren kriterien allen
dass sie sozusagen für den qualitäts
blick gar keinen platz mehr hat ich weiß
jetzt nicht so zu sagen was die neue
ministerin wie hat sich immerhin mit
zwei themen befasst aus dem bereich
familienpolitik nicht mit der
kindergrundsicherung und auch mit kita
öffnungszeiten seien erzieher muss
allein erziehende mutter also man muss
das jetzt noch gar nicht buchen das kann
man auch nicht beurteilen wie sie ihren
job machen wird aber die
absolute also unmöglichkeit dass zum
beispiel jetzt an so hofrat er der ja
nach einem ministeramt durchaus strebte
und strebt das der den familien minister
macht das finde ich also von vornherein
ganz schlecht für die politik und ich
finde es auch faszinierend dass
sozialdemokraten und grüne ist nun gar
nicht hinkriegen also die dass
ausgerechnet das familienministerium mal
anders zu besetzen also ist es ist immer
war den linken ist frauensache und es
gab zwei historische familienminister
franz josef wuermeling und natürlich
heiner geißler beide cdu männer und
beine noch nicht unerfolgreich im amt
geißler war großartig gemacht ja geben
völlig recht man kann übrigens auch
ämter qualifikation sehr viel besser
besetzen ohne dass man die geschlechter
austauscht also frau strack-zimmermann
wäre sicherlich nehme ich an eine sehr
viel besser auf verteidigungsministerin
als war lambrecht aber sie kann ich sie
darf nicht weil sie es aus der fdp aus
der falschen partei lang recht auf meine
linke so
dass man bei der regierungsbildung mal
anfängt von den qualifikationen her zu
denken und dann hinterher sieht wie man
das mit den parteien hinkriegt aber in
diesem fall war die spd sozusagen
diejenige die die suppe versalzen hat
mal die spd hatte einfach verkündet
halbe-halbe halb mann halb frauen und
nachdem lauterbach gesundheitsminister
geworden war musste ins
verteidigungsministerium eine frau an
lassen wir einmal ganz kurz sebastian
geisler politikredaktion erklären wer
ist denn jetzt eigentlich die neue
familienministerin
wie heißt sie was macht sie auch noch
meinen zuschauer abzuholen oder island
haben lisa paus
alleinerziehende mutter eines sohnes sie
ist eigentlich eine fachpolitikern
eigene finanzpolitikerin und tatsächlich
muss ich sagen sie hat so eine gewisse
also ctg ist schon eine gestandene
politikerin die hat auch bereich mit dem
sie sich gut auskennt sie hat vor ein
paar tagen noch eine ganz gute rede
gehalten auch im deutschen bundestag zum
thema inflation also der die ist jetzt
nicht irgendwer auch wenn sie weitgehend
unbekannt war aber was mich bei der
besetzung auch dieses postens zu ärgert
ist es hieß ganz klar es muss eine frau
sein es muss aus dem linken
landesverband muss sie kommen und dann
dieses als drittes kriterium ein mensch
damit die uns keine probleme jetzt schon
wieder macht mir das gut finde ich auch
noch ein bisschen kompetent wir und das
natürlich völlig falsche reihenfolge
warum nimmt man nicht jemanden erstmal
kompetent ist und hat dann nachrangig
irgendwelche anderen kriterien das kann
man ja machen aus irgendwelchen
parteitaktischen erwägungen oder so aber
irgendwie so ja gut wäre gut wenn die
auch ein bisschen was drauf hätte das
irgendwie so irgendwie so nebenbei noch
das dass das ist doch dem normalbürger
überhaupt nicht zu vermitteln eine eine
solche eine solche auswahl es gibt eben
einen weiteren schlimmen trend da kann
man bei ford jetzt auch noch nicht
wissen ob der sich in ihrem manifestiert
oder nicht aber in einem punkt ist ihre
biografie der von frau spiegel ganz ganz
ähnlich nämlich dass sie kaum je
außerhalb der politik gearbeitet hat sie
hat also innerhalb der politik fast alle
ämter innegehabt die in der landes und
bundespolitik denkbar sind in ihrer
partei und es ist ja auch ein stück
qualifikation also ich bin keine
anhängerin davon zu sagen es sollen
experten ganz von außerhalb kommen die
dann von politik wieder nichts verstehen
das funktioniert in der regel dann auch
nicht das ist eigentlich auch häufig
gescheitert dieser versuch aber die
gefahr und das wird immer mehr und
gerade bei den jüngeren wird es noch
mehr dass leute ihr ganzes leben in der
politik verbringen im prinzip nichts
anderes können und auch auf dem
arbeitsmarkt nicht anders vermittelbar
sind das schafft ja auch diese
abhängigkeiten jemand das hat im grunde
bei frau spiegel zu dieser völligen
verzweiflung geführt mit der sie am ende
sich an das amt geklammert hat weil die
frau steht jetzt auch vom nichts also
die ist ja auch direkt aus dem kabinett
in rheinland pfalz hier ins
bundeskabinett gewechselt die hatten
nicht mal ein bundestagsmandat also das
ist ja das eigentliche problem ja wir
haben viel zu viele leute die zum
beispiel studiert haben oder abgebrochen
oder ich habe an frau nahles zum
beispiel unsere frühere spd vorsitzende
arbeitsministerin ja die hat glaube ich
mich frei 20 semester germanistik
studiert hat an ihr die magisterarbeit
über liebesromane geschrieben hat dann
angefangen genießt aber mit der
promotion ja und hat hat dann irgendwie
das nicht zu ende gebracht ja und jetzt
hat sie keinen job gefunden ja weil so
jemand eigentlich irgendwo gebraucht
wird und deswegen wird sie dann
praktisch oberste chefin von jobcentern
ja die märchen ja und ohne abschluss ja
aber das ist ja leid weil es vielen so
also die grünen die haben mir karte war
zwei vorsitzende gewählt die auch ein
abgeschlossenes keinen abgeschlossenen
studium haben das muss jetzt nicht
unbedingt sailer sein also es gibt tolle
leute ohne abgeschlossenes studium zb
bill gates microsoft gegründet hat oder
so aber das ist ja jetzt dass auch ein
anderes kaliber und das finde ich im
grunde das größere problem dass wir
genau was ich sagen viele leute haben
die nie etwas anderes als politik kennen
gelernt studium und dann politik das gab
es früher auch schon mal zu geben bei
helmut kohl war das auch letztlich nicht
viel anders ja aber es wird immer mehr
und jetzt habe ich aber eine gegenthese
doch mal andererseits das jetzt
insbesondere die linken parteien hätte
ich ja jetzt nicht so mag ja dass dies
mit den ganzen quotierungen und so
weiter die stellen sich dann auch selbst
bei mit und dann hätte ich ganz gut als
beispiel bei den grünen ist ja so das
wäre ja normalerweise hätte der hätte es
werden sollen ja jetzt ist die frau bei
lockerer geworden und zwar durch haben
wie schlecht es war also als
kanzlerkandidat fand ich schon mal gut
ja oder bei der spd ist für die
freiesten geworden ja so
dass die ja auch eigentlich außerhalb
der spd glaube ich jeder ziemlich
unsympathisch findet katja oder bei
linken haben sie also die hemmschwelle
ja auch nicht unbedingt eine
sympathieträgerin ist gewählt auch aus
solchen könnte also insofern sage ich
mal dass sie sich selbst ein bein mit
stellen ja da kann ich der sache wieder
was abgewinnen frau gesteht dass sie das
thema vorgetragen muss meine frage
stellen ich hab ja von der deppen
europas geredet sind die anderen länder
was die regierungsbildung
angeht auch schon selbst gefesselt so
verrückt
quotiert und und was die qualifikation
angeht eher witzig verirrt das ist
eigentlich schon alles im detail kann
ich ihnen das für frankreich gar nicht
gar nicht beantworten ich glaube was bei
uns immer dazu kommt ist ein wirklich
ein performative problem und da haben
die franzosen und auch die die italiener
im 2 mehr bella figura und machen es vom
auftreten her einfach besser wir haben
das mit der quote so auf den punkt
gebracht nach dem motto da also da hat
qualifikation im grunde nachrangig zu
sagen also es ist so eine das steht mir
zu haltung entstanden auch sozusagen in
einem bestimmten teil der ministerin
organisierten frauen das dass man es
einfach so sehr sieht da also ich nehme
an also wenn sie sich jetzt britische
kabinette angucken da haben sie ja auch
sehr unterschiedliche qualität so sei
das sieht man es auf anhieb also da
sieht man es durchaus aber es ist wir
haben also durch dieses durch dieses
verfahren durch dieses vorgehen bringen
werde so wahnsinnig deutsch auf den
punkt und das hat ja eine irrsinnige
wirkung wir haben ja im
verteidigungsministerium seit jahren
berichtet darüber was da für ein geld
raus gehauen wird beratungsfirmen weil
die leute die in der spitze des
ministeriums sitzen keine ahnung haben
und sich von iks beratungsform gutachten
hat sich als militär eben auch ganz viel
das kostet ein wahnsinns geld hunderte
von millionen pro jahr völlig richtig
dass exzessive in anspruch nehmen von
beratungsfirmen ist ein großes problem
denn eigentlich ist das ministerium mit
seinen fachleuten dafür da die gesetze
auszuarbeiten und zu schreiben und nicht
irgendwelche externen beratungsfirma
warum dann millionenbeträge gerade frau
von der leyen bademeisterin drin außer
heuer dafür das ist eigentlich eine
verschwendung von steuergeld hatte ja
aber wir haben jetzt eben sozusagen die
dritte verteidigungsministerin
nacheinander die sich also nicht
wahnsinnig oder für diese vielleicht am
wenigsten überhaupt für truppe und und
ausrüstung interessiert und das
natürlich langsam wirklich auch eine
zumutung für flora und fauna die da die
absolut im jahr dienst tun und machen so
ein bisschen angst dass die
verteidigungsfähigkeit angehen halte
mich dass man da noch nichts von putz
bleiben gehört hat aus der führung der
bundeswehr dadurch traten sie noch
wirklich demokratie zu tun das man
stimmt ja wer wurde auch in einer
sendung hier am dienstag frau lambrecht
ein sicherheitsrisiko für unser land
schon als these auch dargestellt wir
sind gespannt was die regierung noch so
in den nächsten monaten macht und jetzt
kommen wir aber zu ihm herr doktor
doktor sind jemand ich muss sie uns
warum sind eigentlich zwei doktortitel
hier bin ja gerne weil ich hatte noch
nie mein leben wir sind sie mit 2 1 aber
dass auch sie müssen sich auch noch mit
einem kleinen aber
danke ich habe zwei doktortitel war
nicht zwei doktorarbeiten geschrieben
hat das ist der ganz einfach und klar in
welchen fächern das müssen noch sagen
geschichte und soziologie und geschichte
da war ich noch ganz jung und in
soziologie das ist erst sechs sieben
jahre her jetzt